chris sims revealed on his podcast
yesterday his top 10 receivers and ma i
tell you what chris the one thing that
just jumped out i know just all capped
bold face
odell beckham jr i know number six uh
yeah and and and you left somebody off
too devonte adams was not in the top ten
and he wasn't happy about it
now everybody give chris sims 1m chris
simps i bet he deliberately spelled your
name wrong i bet he didn't tell him he
is seeking lol anytime i am mad at you
from now on i am going to text you or
put it on the pft show chain as chris
sims s-i-m-s well what's worse what's
worse is it has my twitter handle right
below the comment that says the name so
yeah you're probably right listen this
was not easy it really wasn't and you
know i don't know apparently i don't
think my our producer matt casey is
going to be happy until every position
group in the nfl hates me here so you
know we're just gonna work our way down
the line but
uh the doing a top 10 wide receivers was
very hard and i i listen uh devonte
adams i'm a fan of yours i mean they're
they're i really am i'm sorry i want
these guys to like me but i know when
you do lists you're not going to like
you know guys aren't going to like you
yeah and that's especially if your list
is crazy especially if you have aj green
on there i don't even know that aj green
is still alive well you have him at
number one okay he plays proof of life
of aj he he's still one of the elite
receivers and specimens in the sport you
know when have we seen him do anything
in the past two years okay it wasn't two
years ago it wasn't that far off i mean
it's not totally crazy i know it wasn't
a full year then either but you know
this is still a guy that's 6-4 and runs
4-3 and of course yeah he's been in
cincinnati with some crap around him at
times too but yeah okay he's one i
gambled on a little bit i'm gonna bet he
comes back and you know cincinnati
didn't bat an eye about giving them the
franchise tag so that tells you
something all right you know and then
let's get to the odell beckham jr thing
because it hurt my heart
it hurt my heart i'm not even you know
uh but here's the guy that's been hurt
for three years consecutively and that's
where i get a little scared and as a guy
that he's not he can't depend on size
like some of the other guys he needs his
soft tissue to be explosive and fast and
yeah he's dealt with a lot of injuries
odell beckham jr hitting on all
cylinders and healthy i just need to see
it a little first he is the best
receiver in football but i just don't
know that i need to see it so that's why
i put him at number six behind some guys
that i think are you know been really
damn good and really damn consistent
between keeping him out of the top five
and keeping aaron rodgers out of the top
spot on your quarterback list this has
been a very difficult it's difficult who
would you take out of my top five and
put him in just to give you that real
quick
i i don't i don't know that i i don't
know that you got it wrong i just can't
believe i know we're able to i'm trying
not to be my top five yes i can't i love
you beckham jr i love you i'm sorry
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports